hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again
today is September 19th it is the new
season 11
[ __ ] event let's go sorry for
clapping I'm just very excited it's a
really cool event I cannot wait to share
all this information with you we got
tons of stuff we got a new execution
that's involved with the event new
emotes testing ground info all these new
weapons a ton of new shits it was always
like 3 if you do enjoy subscribe before
new I covered the informational site a
foreigner that being the balance changes
the hero updates the patch alerts and
leaks if we're gonna be kept though
today with everything happening within
the world of foreigner and never miss
Ellen an update if we stay subscribe to
the channel and with that my Twitter and
discard in the description down below
and let's get started so for some
general news in my last video we talked
about the color palettes going away and
some going to neutral since it was too
hard to identify whose team they were on
there was lots of negative feedback with
this and because of that they ended up
reverting the patch that's going to be
going back to normal which is pretty
cool and the referral program is still
alive allowing you to get some friends
and play with them on PC and earn
rewards for them joining if you want to
hear a lot more about that you can click
the I on the top right after you watch
this video it also be at the end so
don't worry about that
it's gonna be going into a lot more
detail cuz I've already spoken about
this before on top of this sadly Luke
Duchene Papa Luke has been working on
the game for six years and sadly he's no
longer with the team but Paschal will be
replacing him in Pascal is such an
amazing men sad to see Luke go but he's
very happy with what he's doing and
everything he's done with the game and
he's obviously very passionate about for
honor and all that stuff he's still
going to be working at Ubisoft just in a
very different branch I don't really
know how the corporate stuff works it's
not really my type of job but yeah he's
still gonna be working with Ubisoft just
probably not with the game or if he's
still working with the game it won't be
at a more personal level like he is on
the Warriors then with us so sad to see
that but it's all good we've had a lot
of replacements recently on the Warriors
then but all the replacements have been
excellent I love all the people that
work on it next up is testing ground
info if you don't know what testing
grounds is it basically was a test to
get all the reworks for season 12 which
is going to be gladiator warlord and
Centurion kind of keeping us up-to-date
and letting us beta test them so that
they are broken on release and phase 1
has officially finished I believe last
week so they're gonna be taking a lot of
the data looking it over and giving us
some
will changes for the reworks and the end
what they state is that we've
accumulated loads of hours I think at
least in the 10,000 hundred thousands of
hours in the indi testing grounds was
about five to six thousand posts on the
survey that they added so awesome shot
it's all you guys that post it on the
survey the next testing ground will have
a custom match and if you don't if you
want to know when just look at one of
the developers glasses you'll see it
right there
but yeah that next testing ground
whatever it will be will have custom
match so we can have the ability to get
into that nitty-gritty detail because
they didn't have a custom match during
the testing and that was kind of sad it
was only just duel and then Dominion but
for going over some of the stuff they
added first Centurion they removed the
cutscene the useful lights like to jab
faint able jab faint able zone was all
received really well and then they plan
on fixing his roll away from jab the
annoying the annoyingness of the light
to jab combo the wall supplied won't
always guaranteed the charged heavy if
you're too close to the opponent when
you do so it won't land but if you're
too far it will it's very weird and very
buggy so they're gonna try to fix that
and then the GB smack move which is the
lion's roar and then some haymaker bugs
the lion's roar isn't getting fixed
there's just some weird bugs with
haymaker kind of pairing it so they're
gonna try to fix that for the rework
when it goes live and if for some other
questionable things our parry punishes
Eagle Talon damage GV vulnerability of
the heavy attacks as well for gladiator
the guard stance the skewer range and
the toe stab as well as the useful
lights were all received pretty well too
and they also plan on to fixing the
toast a bit too heavy and if you change
stance it's not guaranteed it's very
weird I actually ended up testing this
in my game when I was streaming the one
time and I'm glad that that's being
looked at the other stuff is that the
toast that might be to stay to safe and
then the chain side lights are also a
little bit weirder so they do plan on
changing that stuff or maybe looking
looking into it more they don't plan on
changing the deflects for gladiator
they're going to keep it the way that it
is and they also just tried to explain
why Centurion got a lot more reworks
changes than gladiator and warlord for
the upcoming season but I think we
already knew that going in that that was
gonna happen for warlord he didn't
really get much he got some enhanced
lights the heavy finisher on
uninterruptible stuff the full blocks
that improvements were all good
that's about it really nothing to change
though if you are a warlord main and if
you did play the testing ground expect
that exact same build when you hop into
the live game whenever that goes live
probably the beginning of season 12 so
laughs if you're a warlord player you
really don't have to change too much
Centurion gladiator players possibly may
have to change a few things but nothing
too crazy there but yeah with that we
now have the juicy info about the new
event wrath of your man Gunder also I
will be leaving my twitch down in the
description down below its ex gin gy tea
it's a really [ __ ] name still trying to
work on getting that fixed but if you do
want to watch the stream I highly
recommend you do we're gonna be playing
the whole new event the whole time and
everything I say we're gonna be testing
out looking at so definitely come by it
should be I should be live-streaming
right after this video goes live maybe 5
to 10 minutes afterwards but for the
info the new event wrath of the yeoman
Gunder it is going from September 19th
which is today all the way up until
October 3rd and as you could see from
the trailer there's a giant [ __ ]
snake that's going to be in the map
that's the Euro manga under sea serpent
as well as a giant buff that will most
likely be in the breach as a damage buff
will understand as we get later in the
video what that means this event was
inspired in season 9 when the Vikings
were down in the faction war and then
came back as a huge little sweep and won
the entire season seems like they do
that every season though so first up
about the event is we have a new arcade
quest about retrieving the hammer of
Ragnarok and then the other one in the
next week after is about a witch talking
to you about the hammer kind of learning
about it - lore and back story and all
that other stuff as you continue farther
into the quest there will be some
community orders within the quest as
well for some extra steel on top of that
we have the background for the main menu
which I actually really like we have the
new minions from the Knights Vikings and
samurai going from left to right and
then just pulling the event you will get
Emblem outlines as well so even if you
can barely logon in like the next two
weeks that there's live as long as you
can just hop on the game for like two
seconds you will get the new emblem
outline so always just try to do that
just in case there's also going to be
some mood effects at which is lootable
meaning you have to play games to unlock
this this one is called hall des wrath
this includes the emote the idol and the
execution which means you must get all
three of them to unlock all of them it's
like for example if you were to go into
game and you got and it said like Sakura
and then hold those wrath that doesn't
mean that
you've got the e mode the auto and the
execution that means you've got one of
the three so you have to get all three
of them separately to unlock them if you
do want to get all three for the
character there's also going to be some
lootable battle outfits with a nice of
blue color scheme some lootable
ornaments which are also faction based
and remember lootable means you have to
go in game and get those perk you know
when you have to after you beat a game
or after you finish a game they'll
eventually pop up at the end for the
rewards so that's what it means by
lootable this new mask outfit is not
lootable but it is 20,000 steel that you
can buy at Indus faction based you can
get a snake or as Michael on the Dead
stream called it ain't no pro as a mask
they are faction based like I said so
each faction has a similar mask but with
small things to make them slightly
different these are going to be costing
20,000 steel and honestly the Viking and
the Knights are pretty [ __ ] cool the
samurai could be better and the woman
kind of reminds me of the one winter
event mask so do it that as you will
either way still really cool math stuff
I'm going to be picking one of these up
during the event for sure there's also
going to be an execution called the
rampage of Ragnarok for 10000 steel that
launches the [ __ ] out of your opponent
like really really far
honestly obviously there's going to be a
bundle for 30,000 steel that contains
the emote the ornament the effect the
Battle of everything you're seeing on
the screen right now per character so as
usual I recommend playing the entire
event first and then buying the bundle
for the stuff that you haven't gotten
because the ubisoft is not gonna make
you pay double for the same thing
so the more stuff you get that is part
of the bundle the lower the overall
price is so it might not actually be 30k
steel for you it might be 5 k 6k or
maybe even 28,000 if you've only gotten
a couple items and obviously that's for
the first week I'm assuming next week
we're probably going to get some type of
new emote or some other type of
execution to use because that's usually
how these events go but now for the
weapons we have for the event these look
insane lots of variations to fit into
the lore of the characters the woman got
some nice pieces and new show has some
beautiful looking weapons as well
Tanisha always has some really solid
weapons from the Wulin PK automatically
has the best weapon in the entire game
right now with that I super super big
the wardens got some nice little purple
curves in there we got going on set and
glad have some similar color palettes
with an excellent
shield as well and a decent headpiece
for gladiator and so I might grind to
actually get these items surprisingly I
haven't done that in a very long time
because some of these weapons haven't
been the greatest black prior got his
snake shield law bringer has a pretty
nice cool-looking axe and conch has a
very sharp and deadly shield as well
personally I think it's a lot better
than gladiators but Conchas always had a
really good shield that's a conch has
always been about the shield gladiator
hasn't really been about the ship it's
always been about the Trident so I could
totally understand that for the samurai
there's lots of small details like most
of their weapons are they're not giant
big pieces on like their ornaments
there's always a lot of small intricate
details within the craft of the weapon
shinobi's is always going to be
excellent I don't think I've ever been
disappointed by a set of Shinobi weapons
in my life and just like that with new
Shah having two different colors of the
weapons always down for that are Musha
also got the same type of treatment as
shinobi but I feel like his could be
better it kind of reminds me of an
already-existing piece of weapon that
existed I think like a couple seasons
ago that's this red and blue color I
feel like I recognized that somewhere
and then the samurai got some really
nice weapons this time around which is
pretty exciting definitely big finish
you go qisas like his looks like one of
those very big Chinese temples or
Japanese temples I completely forgot
what they're called but you understand
what I'm talking about those things are
[ __ ] big and his weapon is huge and
it just looks really cool the spikes are
deadly I'm loving these weapons this
time around and then lastly the Vikings
were shown Raiders is pretty cool kind
of reminds me of law breakers weapon I
felt they could have done a lot more
with his but it's alright not too bad
and definitely a big fan of shamans
weapons on the Vikings as well always
been a big fan of shaman just like
shinobi you can nurse a theme with these
weapons and I'm totally cool with that
in the past some of these weapons were
okay and some of them were pretty
amazing but I think at least for this
event I think hopefully most of you can
agree that majority of the characters
got some excellent weapons this time
around obviously there's gonna be a few
bad apples in there but I think at least
this time around I would say probably
90% of the cast definitely got some
really good weapons this time and
remember you can either unlock these
with scavenger crates or loot them in
game after the game is finished and you
must use the hero you want for the
weapon the other lootable stuff doesn't
matter for the characters so as a quick
recap if you want the weapons you have
to play as that specific character to
get those parts if you want the outfits
the emotes anything that is lootable
we talked about that is going to be just
anything you just have to keep playing I
totally recommend arcade but I'm like a
separate video for that later in the
future and then the mask outfit in
specific and I also believe the
execution those are going to be costing
steal meaning you cannot loot those you
have to buy those whit steel and then
lastly for this we have the new game
mode this time around called the
Ragnarok instead of a whole new game
mode this time it's more of an addition
of an arty existing mode like before
with the heat so kiri soul game mode
that was a completely original game mode
and very very interesting
whereas this time it's breech but with a
small twist and honestly I'm totally
cooled to twist in the mode the snake
comes up and spawns with the Hammar they
call it it's on a hammer the hum are if
you wield the hum art you can not lock
onto targets you have lower HP you have
infinite stamina you're immune to all
guard breaks all attacks are unblockable
and all uninterruptible and no fall
damage head will occur for there so
really you have no defense no stances
and you can't dodge you can only roll
but as a power move to that you get two
special moves one light and one heavy
attack the light attack which according
to the developers has huge heat range as
they stated has some chain lightning
that affects the people around you this
could be minions this could be soldiers
anybody it affects and the other move is
a heavy attack with an AoE that insta
kills anyone who gets caught in it the
time it takes to land is pretty long so
you can dodge it and you can used all
these moves from the sprint attack which
is pretty cool so super deadly and the
slow mode that you were seeing in the
video right now was not edited by them
was not edited by me that's actually how
slow it is in game which is why it's an
insta-kill
obviously really slow move gonna do a
lot of damage it was expected so try not
to get hit by that and for the rules of
the game mode the last thing we're to be
talking about is that there is no
healing the RAM after the first game
whatever that whatever health your RAM
is going to be at it's gonna be at four
tickets there's gonna be no more tickets
in phase one and two of breach for this
game mode but you will get tickets in
Phase three proportional to how much
help the RAM has so if it has full
health you're gonna get max tickets if
it has half out they're gonna get half
the tickets you normally would or if it
has barely anything you might get four
or five lives to share between the group
so try to keep that thing alive
the main reason of this was some that
attackers don't get smoked with the
hammer and then lose tickets so quickly
because of course this Giants nick comes
out of nowhere spits the hammer in the
middle of the map and you got to fight
for it like it's the flag when you put
it on the RAM or on the gate so don't
lose those so that's why they don't lose
the ticket so quickly and then respawns
are not fixed based on renown out there
going to be just strictly 20 seconds
regardless if you're executed you die
regularly doesn't matter and the
renowned it doesn't matter at all you
could be just starting you could be max
renown it's only going to be 20 seconds
which honestly I really wish that they
just kept that in game regardless but
that's just me that's gonna be it guys
hopefully you guys learned a lot about
the wrath of your men Gunder in this new
event as I said I'm gonna be live on
Twitch playing this probably as soon as
this video is up maybe 5 or 10 minutes
gotta give me a little bit of grace
period here yeah hopefully you guys
didn't enjoy that let me know what you
guys think about this stuff in the
comments down below your favorite weapon
your favorite part about the event
anything about this event just let me
know in the comments below with always
liked the video if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I covered the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch notes and the leaks if
you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update definitely subscribe the channel
that guys have a great stirred a big for
us in the video peace out hopefully I'll
see in this in a live stream as well
doozies
[Music]